DISASTER REL I'VPART
INSISTED ON ITD
-- CITY OF TED.
DO YNKKR
VIABLE PATH TO REGAIN THIT'S LO
IN THE WAR?
I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY MUCH
THEYGAINK THER HERE IS
THERE REALLY IS NO WAY F AND PUR
OR A OR OBJECT.
PUTIN IS
HERE.MBER ONEEY DESIGN
WHERE WE'RE GOIN NES AND THIS II
REGARD O B RETREAT
AND CONTINUE TO LOSEER.
THEY CERTAINLYE
IVE CAPALIOWTHME
UNPREDICTABILITY OF WHAT PUTIN
ISI THAT.
S THATE, ARMY ANEUROPEAN
IBLE THAT HE COULD ERMINE POWER
SO OF
DISTRIBUTION PLACES WHERE THESE
SPLAYS A
ING INSIDE POLAND.
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT NU
E Y  A
RUSSIAN ATTACK INSIDE NATO
TORE, EXAMPLE, AIMING ATHE
AIRPD ORE OTHER
ATO RESPOND?
>> I THINKND ON
THE OTHER AL
WOULD RESPOND.
THERAINLY WOULD BE AN N ONE.
SO, THEREFORE, CERTAINLY
D ON THE NATURE OF
THE ATTACK AND THE SCAND
SC
I THINK THY THE BIGGEST FEAR I
OFT THAN HIM TEIAY NUCLEAR  CEN-
AR WEAPO SEVERAL BY THE
AS T R
INTELLIGENHAT
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING AS T
WHAT THEY'RE SEEIN
SEI'M NOT SAYING THE RISTOAS A
DEMONSTRATION IS Z
I THINK THE RISKS ER TODAYTHANHE
POINT,HE GETS TO THA
POINT, THERE'S PROBABL
SOMETHING HE WOUO
PROBABLY BE, EXAMPLE --
WHAT'S OF A TACTICALNUCLEAR WEA?
OF UKRAINE IS WHAT'M TO LE THID
POTENTIALLY HIS POSITION O HE M
LOGIST P
LOGISTICAL T MAY NOT BE
OF UKRAINE.
IT.THINIT A ION THE MOST BECAUA
LESS ESCOR
TALKING ABOUT ESCALATORY, NG L
NORD
STREAM PIPELINES, EROFFIS KELY
CAY UNDERW EXPLOSIS.IDENT A
RATE ATTACK OF
ES. HAVE EVIDENCE THATRUSSIA IS
NOT GOING TO T ON
INTELLIGEPR
THAV
BLOW UP ON THEIR OWN.S DON'T
SWUR KNOAT THE
VULNERABILITIES ARE AND HAVE
CAPABILITY TO DO IT.
T SERIOUSLY THESE
A FA CHINESE
COUN
DIDEOPLIN REGION WHMOTIVE AND
PADORUSSIAN S
TO ME IT'S NOT AN INTELLCETHIS
I HAVEU ABOUT ZUELA,EN AMERICANS
IN EXCHANGE FOR THOS HAPITH THI
DECISION.
THE WHITE HOUSE ADMITS IT WA
TOUGH. >> T VENEZUELANS RELEASE
DEALERS.
TED AF IN
THE UNITED STATES.N AMERS
THAS A PRICE TAG ON EVER DO THE-
I WANTED THOEOE RELEASED NYNOI
AMERICANS, I CAN HOLD THEM UNT